after a bumpy start Hillary got her  groove back the presidents are often  picked for personality there is concern  in the Hillary camp about how likable  shall be in a general election I may not  be the youngest candidate in this race  but I will be the youngest woman  president in less about filling the  experienced politician and more about  human Hillary the noting grandma who  loves a lot I wish you could be present  proposed its focus less on the fun stuff  they seized on her use of a private  email when she was Secretary of State  painting her devious corrupt and above  the rules in retrospect this didn't turn  out to be convenient at all and I regret  that this has become such a cause  celebra what's still lacking though is  an overarching message fighter for the  middle class might be too beholden to  something a little ball hog if she's  going to finally make that unprecedented  move first lady to commander-in-chief